manufrance le principal actionnaire
menace de partir
le retrait de la macif priverait
l'entreprise d'une partie de l'argent
nécessaire à sa survie
afghanistan la guérilla s'intensifie un
témoignage sur la vie dans les maquis
afghans bonsoir
cet après midi le premier ministre s'est
engagé personnellement dans le conflit
qui paralyse les ports français
monsieur raymond barre procède à une
véritable mise en garde
tout d'abord il constate la situation
porte atteinte aux activités de tourisme
de commerce et de transport et elle
pourrait mettre en cause
l'approvisionnement pétrolier du pays
après quoi le premier ministre formule
sa mise en garde la liberté de
circulation doit être rétablie et
monsieur raymond barre évoque
explicitement le concours actif que la
marine nationale prêterait au
rétablissement du trafic un communiqué
qu'on peut juger particulièrement ferme
jacques hébert oui tout à fait je crois
que l'essentiel pour le comprendre et de
vous le lire presque intégralement il
est assez bref
alors ce communiqué dit tous les
français comprendront que le
gouvernement ne puisse tolérer une telle
escalade qui met en pause
l'approvisionnement pétrolier du pays en
risquant de paralyser sa vie économique
est là le communiqué fait allusion au
port de fos sur mer qui depuis quelques
heures serait l'objet de tentatives de
blocages alors le communiqué poursuit
les marins pêcheurs peuvent faire usage
du droit de grève
reconnu par la constitution mais ce
droit ne les autorisent pas à arrêter le
trafic des ports de commerce et les
activités autres que celles de la pêche
le libre fonctionnement des grands ports
est une obligation de service public
dont le gouvernement assume la
responsabilité et la vient de passage
essentiel de ce communiqué c'est
pourquoi le premier ministre a invité
les ministres des transports de
l'intérieur et de la défense à prendre
les dispositions nécessaires pour
assurer en priorité la liberté de
circulation dans les ports pétroliers
notamment à fos
avec le concours actif de la marine
nationale et le communiqué conclut au
moment où les problèmes de la pêche
français sont examinés selon les
procédures normales de discussions et de
négociations le gouvernement appelle les
marins pêcheurs à prendre une juste
conscience de l'intérêt national alors
que peut-on dire à chaud de ce
communiqué et bien que sa brièveté et
surtout que ça fermait
et donne bien évidemment ce soir une
nouvelle dimension à ce conflit de la
pêche
le premier ministre appelle à la
compréhension et à la sagesse le tout
est de savoir maintenant comment sera
écoutée et comment sera perçu cet appel
dans les ports toujours en grève
c'est donc le gros point d'interrogation
ce soir ce communiqué contribuera-t-il à
l'apaisement ou au contraire durcir at
il les positions quitte dans ce dernier
cas entraîner une éventuelle
intervention de la marine nationale je
crois que la réponse viendra
probablement rapidement dans les heures
qui suivent on constate que ce
communiqué est publié au moment où ce
conflit des marins pêcheurs prendre une
démission une dimension véritablement
politique depuis hier le parti
communiste a demandé une réunion en
session extraordinaire l'assemblée le
parti socialiste a réuni les élus
concernés ils demandent également une
convocation de l'assemblée
la plupart des partis et des
personnalités politiques ont pris
position oui donc dans ce conflit qui
est loin de n'avoir fait que des
satisfaits on pense aux touristes
britanniques aux plaisanciers aux
transporteurs omar hier tous les partis
politiques ont donc pris position sans
exception presque n'aurait plupart des
cas excepté l'udf c'était pour le parti
communiste parti socialiste de rpr la
demande pressante au gouvernement de
favoriser et de partie si même
participer même à des négociations
alors vous savez la réponse du
gouvernement on a entendu
même michel rocard qui parlait d'un
grenelle de la pêche et le gouvernement
répondait face à cela il n'est pas
possible pour l'instant de négocier sur
l'un des points essentiels qui est la
baisse du prix du gazole pourquoi parce
que nous serions en riant contraventions
par un parent au règlement communautaire
de l'europe
alors maintenant ce soir évidemment le
fait l'effet son nouveau le premier
ministre a fait ce communiqué on a pour
l'instant un seule une seule réaction
celle du parti socialiste mais quelques
minutes à peine qui vient d'arriver à
l'instant qui se dit stupéfaite et
inquiète ses méthodes répressives dit le
parti socialiste comprenez qu'il fait là
lyon à l'appel à la marine nationale
l'appel éventuellement y nationale ses
méthodes répressives tiennent mieux pour
le gouvernement de réponse aux demandes
de négociations des pêcheurs le
gouvernement portera la lourde
responsabilité dit le parti socialiste
de toutes les conséquences qui
découleront de cette atteinte à la
liberté
tous ces éléments nouveaux interviennent
au moment où les possibilités de
négociations semblent avoir été épuisés
en effet hier il ya eu vous le rappelez
sans doute l'échec des tentatives de
conciliation au havre et à caen
aujourd'hui il y avait une autre réunion
elle se déroulait à paris cette fois au
ministère des transports où monsieur
joël le theule rencontré le comité
central des pêches est un organisme qui
regroupe les armateurs et les syndicats
la réunion au bout de trois heures et
demie a débouché sur un échec
les réactions des participants au micro
de patrick de carottes
je voudrais rappeler que le carburant
gazole pêche revient aux pêcheurs
effectivement un franc 10 c'est le prix
le plus bas de la communauté il n'y a
aucune taxe mais au contraire une aide
du gouvernement la proposition qui m'a
été fait et par gestes de solidarité
nationale de provoquer une légère
augmentation de l'essence et du gazole
afin que le gazole pêche reviennent à
l'utilisateur 80 centimes j'ai refusé
comme je suis conscient ainsi que le
gouvernement qu'il existe des problèmes
dus aux diversité de situations je
pensais par le jeu d'autres mesures que
j'avais déjà évoqué pouvoir apporter une
aide efficace
on a refusé de les discuter aussi à la
fin de la semaine
à l'initiative des préfets des régions
des réunions se tiendront tél dans
chaque département maritime pour faire
le point très exact et situation car il
ya de très grandes différences et
mercredi prochain lors du conseil des
ministres rendant compte au gouvernement
de ce qui est de ce qui aura été je
serai amené à proposer des celui
monsieur ministre en contrepartie nous a
exprimé son désir de réunir d'ici la fin
de la semaine
un certain nombre de commissions de
caractère local ou régional dont il
espère qu'elle lui pour des propositions
qui lui permettront à lui-même de faire
au prochain conseil des min
des propositions de nature dans son
esprit à résoudre le conflit en cours
l'ensemble des professionnels présents à
afficher son grand scepticisme à l'égard
de cette procédure qui lui paraît de
nature à d'abord dit viser une
profession qui entend rester unis sur
ces deux objectifs fondamentaux et dont
il lui paraît qu'elle ne permettra pas
de résoudre les problèmes qui se posent
à la pêche c'est donc je crois pouvoir
le dire avec incendies mode quand
déception et de grande consternation que
nous avons terminé cette réunion qui
concerne les bleus qu en ce qui concerne
la cfdt
nous appelons tous les marins pêcheurs
de la pêche industrielle et de la pêche
artisanale de continuer leur juste
combat jusqu'à temps que satisfaction
leur soit apportée
nous réunirons dans les délais les plus
rapides
toute notre équipe régionale nationale
afin de tirer les conclusions de cette
néfaste réunion d'aujourd'hui c'est donc
la rupture de la rupture c'est d'autant
plus sa rupture que nous avons perdu
trois heures
le premier ministre demande que les
ports pétroliers sur les livres grâce à
vous d'abord premièrement je pense que
probablement le ministre le gouvernement
va essayer de débloquer les ports
nous avons mis en garde le ministre
devant tout incidents qui pourraient
survenir
nous lui avons dit justement qu'il ne
faudrait pas que malheureusement
périssent en mer dans des opérations de
police des marins luttant pour assurer
leur survie leur emploi leur travail
vous êtes pour la libération des ports
pétroliers alors la situation dans les
ports justement hier en enregistré un
certain assouplissement avec quelques
levée de blocus notamment à cherbourg à
noville à honfleur
il s'agissait en fait de permettre
l'évacuation des voyageurs bloqués dans
des conduits
souvent très pénible mais en revanche
cet après-midi le blocus était rétabli à
peu près partout sauf en corse et dans
l'ouest on enregistrait même une
aggravation avec le blocus du port de
roi le point de la situation avec c'est
lui
à l'entrée de l'estuaire de la seine des
marins pêcheurs normands ont neutralisé
cet après midi à 16h15 leucan le chenal
permettant aux navires de remonter
jusqu'à pour un câble de 200 mètres a
été tendue au travers du chenal qui est
barrée également par une quinzaine de
chalutiers 40 navires environ sont
retenus prisonniers dans les ports
situés entre le havre et rouen et les
bâtiments qui au nombre de trois par
jour à vienne à paris vont également
être bloquée à cherbourg le blocus a été
informé ce matin à 11h15 6500 touristes
britanniques ont donc pu regagner leur
pays
mais une cinquantaine de chauffeurs
routiers bloquent depuis 14 heures la
circulation dans le centre-ville les
routier immobilisé depuis deux jours
dont certains transporte des denrées
périssables ont reçu l'accord de leur
syndicat national ils veulent à leur
disposition deux navires pour
l'angleterre
le port de roscoff est bloqué également
alors qu'il était le seul de la manche
en activité on estime que plus de 7000
bateaux de plaisance sont immobilisés
entre la manche et la vendée situation
inchangée sur la côte sud-ouest de
l'atlantique la rochelle et royan sont
toujours bloqués et un certain
énervement commence à gagner les
plaisanciers la côte méditerranéenne
maintien assez blocus avec en plus celui
très important de la passe du port de
fos sur mer 5 pétroliers sont
immobilisés ainsi que deux minéraliers
répercussions des blocus également sur
les épreuves sportives puisque la course
du figaro d'un pu quitter hier les
sables d'olonne et le tour de france à
la voile étaient mobilisés à port
barcarès
le commandant mark edwards est devenu le
héros de la presse anglaise c'est lui
qui à bord de son bateau a forcé avec
succès le blocus de cherbourg et que le
commandant ne repartent pas avec son
ferry a été la seule condition posée par
les marins de la ville pour la levée du
blocus
hier matin il est donc reparti en avion
dans son pays la situation à l'étranger
maintenant aujourd'hui en début
d'après-midi un message d'un
radioamateurs polonais a provoqué une
brusque poussée de fièvre dans les
chancelleries et dans les salles de
rédaction
ce message qui a été capté par
différents postes en allemagne de l'ol
ce message annoncé l'entrée des troupes
soviétiques en pologne s'exprimant dans
un mauvais allemand le radioamateur
polonais lancé un véritable appel de
détresse
quelques minutes plus tard les démentis
tombées en cascade démenti tout d'abord
des autorités de varsovie démenti
également du pentagone à washington où
aucun mouvement de troupe inhabituel n'a
été constatée en pologne
les autorités militaires américaines
ajoute que l'union soviétique dispose
déjà en pologne 2-2 division motorisée
comptant chacune plus de douze mille
hommes un nouvel envoi de troupes
soviétiques est donc considéré comme
très improbable cependant le fait que ce
message anonyme et suscité des démentis
au plus haut niveau constitue un indice
de l'inquiétude croissante provoquée par
ces événements de pologne la situation
est toujours bloquée d'une part le
mouvement de grève s'étend et d'autre
part les fils du dialogue ne sont
toujours pas noué entre le pouvoir et
les grévistes chaque gagnant du moulin
ces grévistes à danse comme ailleurs les
autorités s'efforcent en vain de diviser
leur mouvement
comment est bien en tentant de les
persuader de négocier leurs
revendications entreprise par entreprise
et puis de reprendre le travail et la
danse comme dans les nouvelles villes
gagnées par la grève as tu est in
dossier ni sa langue au recul ce cas les
travailleurs exigent que les
négociations s'engagent d'abord avec les
comités interentreprises qui ont été
formés dans ces régions et dans ces
villes est partout on s'installe dans la
grève le ravitaillement et parfaitement
organisés facilitée par les dons de
sympathisants
une association comme celle des
écrivains de danse
l'impasse actuelle risque de durer car
la commission gouvernementale envoyé à
danse se refusent à négocier avec les
comités de grève inter entreprises ou
les éléments intransigeant au dissident
domine nettement hors ces éléments qui
sont qualifiés officiellement d'anti
socialistes semblent largement soutenu
par les ouvriers de la base qui
insistent plus que jamais sur leurs
revendications politiques comme en
témoigne une interview filmée par la
télévision suédoise
à l'issue d'un des nombreux meetings qui
se sont déroulés à dents a été votre
réaction lors du discours du club en
direct la télévision grecque ne rien il
conclu cela fait dix ans qu'il aurait
fait la même chose les comités des
grains vie si évidente qui réunit toutes
les usines réclament des mesures
concrètes au champ de bataille
pensez vous que vous gagnerez ce combat
oui bien sûr nous sommes ici pour gagner
quelles sont vos revendications les plus
importantes la création de syndicats
libres vous pensez que la situation
changera si vous obtenez satisfaction
nous pensons que oui cela prendra du
temps oui cela prendra du temps et des
autres revendications seront courts
plus tard vous résisterez longtemps
probablement vous êtes prêt à accepter
un compromis
probablement pas pourquoi pas nous avons
accepté trop souvent des compromis vous
pensez que ceux qui sont au pouvoir ont
l'intention d'utiliser la force pour
mettre fin à la grève
probablement d'autre part le pape jean
paul ii pour la première fois depuis le
début de cette crise a fait allusion aux
événements de pologne c'était
aujourd'hui au cours de l'audience
hebdomadaire place saint pierre et la
demande et en italien aux fidèles de
prier ou sa patrie la pologne
on s'oriente depuis hier de très
violentes attaques israéliennes sont
dirigées contre le sud liban hier
c'était l'artillerie et des blindés
aujourd'hui les bombardements aériens et
ces attaques auraient fait plus d'une
cinquantaine de morts les israéliens
reconnaissent l'intervention et affirme
qu'elle est dirigée contre des
concentrations de [ __ ] françois-xavier
d'eau
le raid israélien qui a eu lieu cette
nuit dans la région de la bâtie au sud
liban est le plus important depuis 1978
israéliens ont utilisé des troubles
médicaux portée tandis que d'autres
progresser par ter venant du sud
l'opération a été accompagné les tirs
d'artillerie et de bombardements aériens
le château de beaufort construit jadis
par les croisés et tous les palestiniens
tirer sur les milices chrétiennes a été
endommagée ainsi que la ville de
nabatiyeh quartier général des
palestiniens selon les israéliens
cette opération était un acte de
représailles à la suite des récents tirs
de roquettes en provenance du sud liban
sur le nord est de la cisjordanie
occupée
le raid israélien a provoqué une vive
réprobation tant de la part des
etats-unis de la grande-bretagne de la
france que du monde arabe
quant aux forces des nations unies les
combats avaient lieu derrière leur ligne
elles ne sont pas intervenus du côté
libanais on constate avec amertume que
ceux qui condamnent d'israël reste d'un
puissant à l'empêcher d'agir et se
contente en fait de compter les coûts
cette fois ci ils ont pu en compter 2480
c'est le nombre des obus israéliens qui
sont tombées sur le théâtre des
opérations
et justement hier alors qu'il se rendait
sur les lieux des combats des devoirs
les images les membres de l'équipe de
tf1 ont été atteint par l'explosion
d'une caisse de munitions piégé
abandonné par les israëliens forte
heureusement pour eux ils étaient à
l'intérieur de la voiture dans la
carrosserie les a protégés mais le
caméraman bernard guerni a été blessé à
la jambe
son état n'inspire aucune inquiétude
quant à julien galeotti et richard marie
ils sont sortis indemnes de cet incident
nous venons de recevoir aujourd'hui le
premier reportage de notre envoyée
spéciale chargée de couvrir les
opérations françaises de secours en
ouganda
jean-pierre abou accompagne la mission
militaire qui viennent installer son pc
sur l'aéroport dans le tb à quelques
kilomètres de la capitale ougandaise
et c'est à partir de là que les secours
en vivres et médicaments pourront être
acheminés vers les régions sinistrées
sur l'aéroport d'entebbe et que nous
avons assisté à l'arrivée à
l'installation des militaires français
chargé de l'opération dette d'urgence
dans le karamoja pour la population de
400 mille habitants est décimée par la
famine
les vivres les médicaments pourraient
être distribués aux populations car
amazon grâce à deux hélicoptères puma
qui sont arrivées de pau en pièces
détachées à bord d'un avion militaire
transall et d'un avion cargo civil nous
avons assisté au montage du premier
plumas ici dans un hangar de l'aéroport
dans tb cette opération d'assistance est
effectué par 41 militaires français qui
porte leur uniforme en accord avec les
autorités ougandaises mais qui ne sont
pas armées
lundi 18 août nous avons rejoint la base
de son rôti au sud-ouest du karamoja à
bord du premier hélicoptère puma
c'est à partir de cette base tenu par
l'armée tanzanienne à 250 km au nord
ouest de kampala que les hélicoptères
distribueront tous les jours trois
tonnes de vivres aux enfants kara mages
ont menacé de mort par la famine a sorti
nous avons rencontré le lieutenant
colonel fils terre qui dirige l'aide
militaire française nous allons faire
dès demain les premières reconnaissances
nécessaire dans l'est et dans le nord de
caraman jean façon à reconnaître les
emplacements des missions et des
différents hôpitaux
cette opération humanitaire française
qui commence a été très appréciée par le
gouvernement et par la population
ougandaise
nous avons rencontré des médecins des
organisations humanitaires qui
travaillent ici dans le karamoja pour
eux cette opération va être déterminant
elle va leur permettre de pouvoir sauver
des milliers d'enfants car amazon dans
les endroits les plus reculés les
endroits qui ne sont pas accessibles au
convoi des nations unies parce qu'il
faut bien dire qu'ici dans le karamoja
il n'y a pas que la sécheresse qui soit
responsable de la famine
il ya également des bandes de pillards
3000 pillards qui s'attaque au pourvoi
des nations unies et qui interdisent le
ravitaillement de la population grâce
aux hélicoptères des enfants karama jour
dans les endroits les plus reculés pour
pouvoir être ravitaillée si elles sont
commence à s'améliorer un petit peu dans
la mesure où les convois sont sont
organisés beaucoup mieux qu'il ya
quelques temps les camions sont
disponibles et livrent régulièrement les
différents centres pour la famine ou la
famille s'est déclarée le problème reste
maintenant le même dans les
dans la périphérie descente dans les
petits villages où les enfants ne peut
croiser passé où les gens sont trop
faibles pour pouvoir arriver jusqu'au
centre et le problème donc maintenant
d'aller jusqu'à c'est le but qu'on se
propose d'atteindre maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il ya encore des enfants kara mahjong
qui meurent de faim dans six endroits
dans les villages il ya certainement des
enfants qui meurent de faim dans les
centres importants dans les villes dans
les sous conté on peut
on peut dire la situation est nettement
meilleure et que les enfants ne meurent
plus de faim
ici les médecins et les organisations
humanitaires estiment que l'aide au
carat moja devrait continuer au moins
jusqu'à l'été prochain si l'on veut
empêcher la disparition de toute une
race pour la première fois depuis
l'arrivée des troupes soviétiques en
afghanistan
des accrochages ont eu lieu avec les
maquisards en plein jour à proximité de
l'aéroport de kaboul les combats ont
éclaté avant-hier et d'après certains
témoignages il aurait fait plusieurs
dizaines de victimes de part et d'autre
un autre témoignage vient de nous
parvenir aujourd'hui grâce à philippe
roger il accompagnait le premier convoi
de ravitaillement de la icf action
internationale contre la faim les
secours transportés par ce convoi était
d'origine française est destinée aux
populations du nouristan c'est une
région située au nord-est du pays
philippe roger raconte à christian
bousquet comment il a pu atteindre cette
région est ce qu'il y avait nous sommes
partis de peshawar avec un camions
chargés de deux tonnes de vivres de
secours d'hiver jusqu'à un village de
base
quelque part la frontière pakistano
afghane de là nous sommes partis de nuit
à la fois pour éviter la police
pakistanaise
et pour passer sans encombre le col qui
a été miné par les soviétiques
enfin nous avons fait trois jours de
marche à peu près jusqu'à kamdesh qui
est la capitale du nouristan est votre
convoite ils étaient attaqués sur le
trajet l'aviation soviétique intervient
tel dans ce secteur de l'afghanistan non
nous n'avons pas été attaqué il ya trois
mois à peu près que l'aviation
soviétique n'intervient plus sinon pour
miner avec des hélicoptères la région
frontalière
cela dit nous avons vu beaucoup de
villages détruits qui l'ont été depuis
janvier à peu près oui alors justement
vous avez ramassé
les débris d'une de ses mines
antipersonnel larguée par les
hélicoptères soviétique je crois en
effet ces mines se présentent comme de
petits objets qui se confondent avec le
paysage elles sont vertes dans cette
région qui est une région boisée
elle se compose d'un corps et d'une
ailettes l'ailette permettant à ses
mines de tomber en tournoyant les
afghans les comparer à des oiseaux à une
aile et de se poser sans exploser
ensuite deux détonateurs provoque la
détonation au moindre choc
il faut dire que le drame de ce procédé
c'est que c'est surtout la population
civile qui en souffrent les blessés que
nous avons vu à peshawar et ailleurs
sont surtout des nomades et des enfants
sans parler du bétail qui lui aussi est
victime de ce minaj alors comment avez
vous été accueilli par les villageois
avec votre congrès de ravitaillement
écoutez il faut dire que les afghans les
nourrices thani se sentent isolés et ce
centre est abandonnée par les pays
occidentaux
c'est donc avec beaucoup de joie qu'ils
ont vu arriver une aide et c'est ed
nous espérons la continuer il faut dire
aussi que les campagnes que nous menons
pour les approvisionner en vivres ne
sont pas suffisantes
du moins leurs yeux et que la chose qui
le réclament avec une assistance une
permanence c'est des armes c'est des
armes capables de résister contre les
hélicoptères blindés soviétiques contre
l'aviation soviétique retour en france
et retour à l'actualité sociale une
nouvelle menace pèse sur manufrance le
principal actionnaire de l'entreprise
stéphanoise entreprises en difficulté
pourrait décider de se retirer cet
actionnaire c'est la macif
c'est une mutuelle de la région de niort
et la macif réunira son conseil
d'administration samedi afin de se
prononcer sur cet éventuel retrait après
quoi dans une semaine ce sera la réunion
du conseil d'administration de
manufrance christian barquisseau le
directeur général de l'ama s'ils
envisagent en fait un retrait pur et
simple de sa participation au conseil
d'administration de la société
stéphanoise
la macif mutuelle des assurances des
commerçants et industriels de france
détient déjà rappelons le 30 % du
capital de la société nouvelle
manufrance ce retrait du conseil est
expliquée par son directeur général
monsieur jacques vandier
une circulaire adressée au début de la
semaine à tous les centres et bureaux de
la mutuelle ces arguments sont les
suivants les autres actionnaires qui
devait compléter le capital nécessaire
renflouement de manufrance sont absents
les garanties réclamées par la macif
n'ont pas été obtenues et l'aide de
l'état est assorti de conditions
inacceptables
rappelons que l'état s'est déclaré prêt
à accorder une aide de 150 millions de
francs
à condition que la macif s'engage
également financièrement et qu'il y est
un véritable plan pour restaurer les
équilibres financiers de la société
stéphanoise qui perd actuellement 10 à
12 millions par mois ce plan de
restructuration supposerait en plus le
licenciement de six salariés sur les
1800 75 que compte encore mal et france
et ce sont de telles mesures que la
macif ne veut pas prendre en charge ce
retrait de la macif qui sera décidé
samedi met en cause l'existence même de
manufrance hier le bruit courait que le
groupe bidermann le numéro un français
du vêtement était prêt à prendre le
relais mais le groupe a démenti
aujourd'hui cette information
la catastrophe aérienne qui s'est
produite hier soir à riyad en arabie
saoudite est certainement l'une des plus
cruelles de ces dernières années jugez
plutôt un triste heures en avion jumbo
de la compagnie séoudienne d'école en
direction de djeddah équipage et
passagers en tout il ya 300 personnes à
bord à 80 kilomètres de l'aéroport un
incendie se déclare dans l'appareil le
pilote rebroussent chemin
malgré le feu il réussit à poser le
street le tristar sans dommage
on peut croire que le pire est évité
mais non les pompiers n'arrivent pas à
maîtriser le sinistre
dans l'avion les hôtesses ne parviennent
pas à ouvrir les portes et les issues de
secours
pris au piège des occupants de
l'appareil 300 personnes je vous le
rappelle ont péri carbonisés
il n'y aura aucun survivant la violence
a repris à amsterdam contre les
squatteurs et la police depuis plusieurs
années dans cette ville qui connaît une
grosse crise du logement des jeunes ont
entrepris d'occuper les immeubles
laissés vides par leurs propriétaires
les autorités avaient tout d'abord
fermer les yeux mais le phénomène a pris
de l'ampleur
déjà il y avait eu des incidents graves
lorsque les squatteurs avaient perturbé
le couronnement de la reine au mois de
mai on estime à près de 10000 maintenant
le nombre de ces squatters il ne se
fasse pas de semaine sont de nouvelles
occupations d'immeubles amsterdam et
dans les autres grandes villes
hollandaises
les éleveurs de porcs ont bloqué
l'aéroport de brest durant une partie de
la journée en envahissant les pistes
avec une centaine de citernes à purin la
police les a fait dégager au milieu
d'après-midi les éleveurs entendaient
protester contre les importations de
porc en provenance des pays extérieurs
au marché comme la mort dans une rivière
une tonne et demie de poissons flotte le
ventre à l'air à la surface de la cciad
près de mandelieu dans les
alpes-maritimes
ces poissons étaient vraisemblablement
asphyxiés par des boues industrielles
la municipalité a déposé une plainte
contre x et puis pour terminer le
rappelle bien sûr du loto il fallait
jouer le vin le 16 le 48 le 39 le 1 le
12 chiffres complémentaires le 31 voilà
et pour terminer ce journal le temps
aujourd'hui les températures allaient de
20 à 25 degrés parfois même au delà des
températures légèrement supérieures
moyenne cette période de l'année demain
sur le sud du pays du soleil et de la
chaleur sur la moitié nord de nombreux
passages nuageux avec quelques averses
sur les départements du nord et du pas
de calais voilà ce journal est terminé
merci de votre attention
la dernière édition sera présentée comme
chaque soir par joseph poli passer une
bonne soirée
puis vous verrez